yeah you're like uh one of the I mean I
would say the top two or three video
directors in the game right now I
appreciate that you've done
I mean you did the Box video
uh I mean you've done so many videos so
like what are like the bigger like just
kind of run down some of your obviously
you got started with Russ we'll get into
that but like give me some of your like
highlights of the last like couple of
years uh honestly um so that's a
confusion I'm a production company and
I'm also a director so so your your
company is blank Square yeah so blank
square and so basically uh I have 12
directors on my company and then I'll
including myself so then I direct
projects and they also do projects
um I like to be involved in a little bit
everything just kind of like just about
the culture and just showing people how
to get things and how to treat artists
um but yeah it comes into a situation
where I think a lot of the people always
like damn your videos are everywhere
it's like no my company is everywhere so
what about your company what what are
the bigger videos of the last few years
that blank Square's handled oh man you
know we just did the handsomer remix
video with Tiffany haddish that was cool
that one was dope it was like a little
mini movie yeah 100 I'm just trying to
bring back that like that old Chris
Robinson that old you know like Jesse
Torero skips
um type of videos but um on other videos
though uh what else yeah they're just so
many
um the videos that were about to come up
is like you know we're shooting Nikki
next week so that's gonna be cool
um can't see the record yet but well I
think it's the one she's probably been
teasing right the freaky girl record no
just you know surprised for everybody
you know what I'm saying but um but yeah
I'm excited about that and yeah man just
there's so many videos at this point
like I was just in Mexico shooting a big
artist out with their name Diana Paola
so and she has a huge following I was
out compared to kind of like you know
she's like that new girl in Mexico
um on the rise and yeah it's pretty cool
man just to try to like just work with
different artists and different levels
of their career right uh there was a
video which video did you do that Tiana
Trump was in
oh the throat Baby remix yeah throat
baby yeah I'd be forgetting all the
videos we'll be doing honestly but that
was a crazy ass video yeah a lot of
people were talking about it especially
at the baby scene where yeah yeah you
know it's funny because uh me and my
friends were honestly we're just like
smoking weed and we're just like in my
living room and we're just talking about
it I play the record and we all honestly
just came up with a scene and we were
just like having fun with it and we're
like yo how nasty can you get with it
and but still like making it in a cool
way and yeah one of my friends was like
yo what if uh the baby was uh you know
surfing down a tongue and then someone
else said like yeah like this and then I
was like yeah we'll put the goggles on
them and then like we just started like
collaborating on the idea and then we're
like you know what we wrote Into the
treatment and uh lvrn who manages BRS
cash was like we love the idea we want
to be provocative and and it worked it
worked yeah